Tụi quan sòa thảo để sốt điều trình lên quan tuổi nhận chợ cấp khu chi sà hội,
đây là tận an sing mới dành trong người tử đủ bệm lắm tuổi chờ lên,
mà không có lương hiệu bọng chợ cấp bọ hiểm xà hội hàng tháng.
Tự thiện từ tháng bây nằm hàng nhỉ khu trong hàng lắm.
Với hộ ngào tựng ngào, tuổi hưởng tử đủ bệm mới đến dưới bệm lắm.
Mất chờ cấp hiện hưởng nằm trong nghìn đau mối tháng,
dư thảo nếu hai thương an xe đổi, phương an một dựng bên như quy định hiện hàng biệt điều trình giảm dân
tội thuộc hưởng thuộc thẩm gren quỏ quy bán thử bụng khu khội trên cơ sở đến gý của chính phủ.
Phương an hai là bộ xung quy định theo hưởng chính phủ quy định điều trình giảm dân đau tội hưởng
chợ cấp yêu chi sà hội, xuống lụi bệm tội phù hợp điều két phát triển kinh tệ sà hội
và hả năng ngân sách tưởng thời ký, trên quy bán thử bụng khu khội điều trình giảm dân đau tội hưởng
xuống dưới bệm mới khi đủ điều két thần thiết.
Cốc ý về nội dung này có tà mụng ngàn cơ quan đồng tình về phương an một,
hơn 5 cơ quan đơn vị lợi trọt thử an hai,
theo bộ nội bụng chính sách giảm tội nhận chợ cấp yêu chi sà hội
từ tà mơ sụ bệm lâm thực hiện từ tháng bây nấm hình y khu trăm hâm lâm
đã đưa thêm khoảng 5,000 người vào lời ăn sinh,
nâng tỷ lệ mảo vụ lễn gần 1,500,
sông tỷ lệ này vẫn còn xa, xò, với mục tiêu nghị quyết hai mị tám của chúng ơn,
đến năm hình y khu trăm hâm mơ hình khoảng 7,000 xong người xau tuổi nghị hưu được hưởng yêu chi
chợ cấp mảo hiểm xau hạng tháng, phó chợ cấp yêu chi sà hội
việc giảm dần tuổi hưởng gó phần từ kẹt mục tiêu chú hương đề ra,
bất tình thêm một phẩy tám chụng người được tuổi hưởng chính sách ký giảm từ mấy mâm lâm xuống mấy mùi tội,
kinh phí thực hiện mấy môi nguyên mấy chăm tỷ lộm mỗi nâm.